you'll hear people talking about
different ways of looking at gdp and in
general they'll talk about the
expenditure view of gdp
expenditure view of gdp versus the
income view of gdp and to realize why
these get you to the same number for gdp
but while you're kind of conceptually
looking at two different things we're
going to revisit a very very simple
economy maybe slightly more complicated
than that one island economy so in this
economy we have some households and
that's why it's slightly more
complicated i'm not saying households
not just one house on an island so you
have some households and you have some
firms
and you have some firms and for the sake
of simplicity we're going to assume that
households own all the factors of
production own all
factors
of
of production and they essentially rent
them out to firms to produce all the
goods and services so all the firms so
this is another assumption produce all
the goods and services produce
all
goods
and services now these are two very
strong assumptions and it's really not
true in the real world this just helps
me draw the diagram obviously in the
real world households do not own all of
the factors of the production many if
not most of the factors are factors of
production the the
the factories and the ships and whatever
else are actually owned by firms in the
real world but this is not that crazy of
an assumption because those firms at the
end of the day are owned by people they
are owned by households so in theory
that they could have been transferred to
the households and then the households
just rent the factors of production to
the firms and this is also a hugely
simplifying assumption because we know
that in the real world firms don't
produce all the goods and services that
households also produce goods and
services some of which never get
mentioned get measured the the service
of me taking the trash out at night
or doing the lawn or making dinner or
the service of of of parents taking care
of their children none of that gets
accounted for but for this
just for simplicity we're going to make
these two assumptions all the factors of
production the and let's list them the
labor
the labor the land
the capital and if we want to throw it
in the entrepreneurship it's all owned
by households and all the goods and
services are produced by firms
so just like we saw with that first
example of the island the households do
all of the expenditures and this ends up
being all of the revenue
all of the revenue for the firms and
then the firms spend a lot you take that
revenue and then spend it to rent many
of these factors of production or some
or all of these factors of production so
they hire people which is essentially
renting labor they might rent the land
they might rent the capital so all of
that ends up becoming income all of that
ends up becoming income for the
households and whatever else is left
over so this is expenses
this is expenses so if you take this
revenue what's what it turns into is
expenses and profit
whatever's left over after expenses is
profit but we're assuming all the firms
are also owned by all the households so
the expenses plus the profit end up all
going to the households and becoming
income
which then becomes expenditures
expenditures for the household which
then become revenue
revenue for the firms so when people say
the expenditure versus the income view
of gdp they're saying look i could
measure gdp at any one of these points i
could measure the expenditures in a time
period by households in this very simple
model which would be the same as the
revenue of firms in this very similar
model which is the same as the expenses
plus the profit of the firms in the
simple model which is same as the income
of the household
and so the expenditure the expenditure
view of gdp would be looking in this
very simple model we'll see it gets
complicated very fast especially when we
start thinking about expenditures not
just coming from households but this is
a simplifying a hugely simplified model
to show you that these are the same
thing would say hey let's look at gdp at
this point
maybe at that point and if we wanted to
look at the income model we could look
at gdp at
at that point what we'll see as we go
into future videos and we start to break
things between consumption and
investment in government spending and
net exports that it isn't quite this
simple to diagram out but when we do
think about that we are thinking when
we're talking about consumption and
investment in government we are thinking
of it from the expenditures point of
view there's another way of thinking
about it where you could have looked at
the aggregate income in that country's
point of view making some adjustments
for things like exports and imports and
things like that but hopefully that at
least clarifies why these come up with
the same number from you can see it in
this very simple model and that they are
two slightly different lenses on the
same thing